Salut!
Nous sommes de retour dans mon bureau
Toute la semaine dernière je n'étais pas à la maison
Donc je vous ai fait les vidéos dans mon autre bureau
Mais là c'est bon, je suis de retour
Rassurez vous la bibliothèque n'a pas bougé.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai utilisé le titre très putaclic:
"Retenir les dates en Histoire"
Parce que cette vidéo va parler de
Comment retenir les dates en Histoire
Quoi j'en aurai marre qu'on dise que les titres sont putaclic
pour un oui ou pour un non
[En riant] Oui c'est possible
Générique
*Musique du Générique*
On va faire ça en quelques points très rapide
Premier point, pour essayer de retenir une date pour un événement historique
Il faut penser à globaliser l'événement.
Prendre le temps de le remettre dans son contexte au niveau national
voir même au niveau mondial
et aussi en terme de durée.
Prenons la guerre de 100 ans,1337 pour la guerre de 100 ans
est ce que c'est un événement globalisable?
OUI
Déjà ça s'appelle La guerre de 100 ans, ça dure un petit peu plus que 100 ans
ça fini en 1453.
Mais surtout le premier job à faire c'est de se rappeler un peu
Quel était l'état de la France à ce moment là
A quoi ressembler la France?
Quels sont les enjeux de la guerre de 100 ans?
Est ce que vous pouvez vous lire une petite histoire, un petit résumé qui vous remet le contexte,
Qu'est ce qui se passait en Europe, à cette époque là?
Qu'est ce qui se passait dans le monde à cette époque là?
Quels sont les autres événements marquants ayant eu lieu durant la guerre de 100 ans?
Quand vous répondez à toutes ces questions pour apprendre une date,
Ça vous permet d'avoir une image précise.
Et quand bien même vous pourriez oublier la date précise
vous pourriez toujours en parler en remettant l'événement dans un contexte
qui montre que vous avez retenu la chose la plus essentielle
à savoir
quand est ce que ça se passait approximativement
Ensuite il existe pleins de techniques pour pouvoir apprendre,
on va dire un petit peu à force de répétition comme les flashcards
Je vous avais fait une vidéo là dessus, je vous invite à la regarder en cliquant ici
vous pouvez évidemment utiliser votre table de rappel habituelle si vous avez déjà fait ce travail là
on a vu ça toute l'année ensemble.
Mais sans aller jusqu'à la table de rappel, vous pouvez quand même le faire un petit peu plus simplement
en créant une espèce de table de rappel improvisée
C'est à dire en utilisant des images et une espèce d'histoires que vous allez pas forcément retenir précisément
c'est pas là le but
Le  but, c'est de créer des accroches mentales pour créer des sillons entre chacun de vos neurones.
Le cerveau aime se souvenir, des vrais souvenirs justement,
de tout ce qui est visualisable,
donc ça va améliorer ce processus avec une logique intérieure qui vous est propre
et vous pouvez même ajouter des rimes là dessus
Reprenons notre exemple de la guerre de 100 ans
pour se souvenir de la fin
c'est quand la ville de Bordeaux est prise par le Roi Charles VII.
Ça se passe le 19 octobre 1453.
Alors, je vais vous expliquer maintenant comment j'ai retenu le 19 octobre 1453
Le 19 octobre c'est la date d'un ami, d'un de mes meilleurs amis
donc là j'avoue c'est facile j'ai juste pris mon meilleur ami,
comme ça en exemple dans ma tête,
je le visualise OK
Et je le visualise en train d'arrivée dans la ville de Bordeaux
et 1453 je sais déjà que c'est dans l'époque de 1400
puisque je connais déjà la date de départ dans les années 1300
et que c'est une guerre de 100 ans.
Et bien sans me faire une image particulière
je me rappel juste que ce sont des nombres qui se suivent mais mélanger
ils ne sont pas dans le bonne ordre
donc par rapport à la guerre de 100 ans qui est en 1300,
je sais que c'est 3, 4, 5 mais faut mélanger un petit peu tout ça
et comme au bout de 100 ans on arrive dans les année 1400
et bien je sais que c'est 1, 4, 5, 3.
Ça c'est mélangé.
Dis comme ça, ça vous parait sûrement encore plus complexe
mais c'est que je n'ai pas fait un travail d'image à retenir complet
je cherche juste des choses qui me parle,
des petites logiques
Pour pouvoir réactiver des chemins mémoriels qui vont revenir plus facilement,
que si j'essayais d'apprendre la date par cœur.
Parce qu' également, à chaque fois que je vais essayer de me rappeler de cette date,
je vais retrouver une certaines forme de logique
et ça va m'assurer que je suis sur la bonne route
en terme de mémoire
et le fait d'avoir globaliser l'événement dans un environnement et dans un contexte,
ça va me permettre d'être sûr que je suis dans les bonnes tranches d'année en terme de siècle
Vous pouvez également apprendre des petites phrases très courtes,
comme dans la dernière vidéo que je vous ai faite sur les moyens mnémotechniques pour retenir 10 choses
Pour les présidents français j'avais créer une phrase où chaque 1ère lettre de 1er mot
correspondait à un des présidents.
Alors que c'était plus un procédé mnémotechnique dans les phrases pour retenir les présidents américains
mais il existe un autre système dont je vous avais parlé pour mémoriser Pi,
pour ceux qui veulent bien s'amuser cette semaine,
où l'on créé une phrase où chaque mot contient un nombre de lettre
et ce nombre de lettre une fois qu'on l'a converti en chiffre nous donne une donnée particulière.
Ça pourrait très bien être une date
Dans la phrase: "Ô Soleil fait Roi",
je peux retrouver 1643.
Ô c'est une lettre, Soleil c'est 6 lettres, fait F A I T c'est 4 et Roi c'est 3,
1643 et bien c'est l'année du sacre du Roi Soleil
Evidemment si vous allez faire un tour dans ma playlist sur la mémoire
vous allez retrouver des informations sur le map mind, sur les tables de rappel,sur le palais mental,
Toutes ces techniques de base sur la mémoire vous permettent assurément de bien retenir des dates,
mais si vous voulez pas fournir cette effort complet pour retenir plus facilement des dates,
ou juste simplement
quand vous avez un contrôle à réviser,
quand vous voulez apprendre quelques choses en terme de culture générale etc...
Utilisez juste ce que je viens de vous expliquer aujourd'hui
à savoir la globalisation et des techniques qui vous seront personnelles
en nombre de lettres, en astuces mnémotechniques ou alors en image qui vous vienne comme ça
ou en logique personnelle
pour pouvoir créer un chemin dans votre mémoire un peu plus précis et un peu moins abstrait
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regarder cette vidéo
j'espère que ça vous aura plu
et si c'est le cas, vous pouvez mettre un pouce en l'air
c'est toujours aussi important
Bienvenue sur la chaîne si vous venez d'arriver via la vidéo de Pierre Croce
qui était assez marrante puisque c'est la première vidéo sur les 326 où j'ai eu un plantage
alors si vous voulez voir quand je réussi à faire quelques choses vous pouvez regarder dans les anciennes vidéos
par exemple dans la playlist "Tour de Mentalisme"
Et merci, à vous tous, les abonnés qui êtes là depuis le départ ou en cours d'année
On est aujourd'hui le 22 novembre,
on a passé la barre de 175 000 personnes qui suivent cette chaîne
Merci à vous tous
et comme les vrais reste jusqu'au bout de la vidéo,
je vais vous le dire.
C'est mon anniversaire aujourd'hui et 175 000 abonnés c'est un beau cadeau
Merci beaucoup et rendez vous demain à 17h
puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre. Rendez vous demain OUI
Tchao !